hello reject nation Greg here John here
we're going to watch today from one of
our friends art Speer Entertainment
supervillain bolt in Sandwich I remember
the first thing we ever saw from them I
was watching a video with Andrew
superhero Bowl which is awesome and now
we're gonna get the supervillain one
there's gonna be exciting nostalgia
ready player one we love it don't we
yeah 100% before we do that I want to
say thank you to everyone at our patreon
for joining us this month everyone has
been pledged and all the new pledges as
well if we actually got a special video
coming out in my new Jana that you guys
should keep a lookout for Lily you'll
know with that in mind let's get a
patron today shout out because this is
all animated this is all art let's give
a shout out to Erica Tuesday John she's
your close buddy why don't you take it
away
that's right G Erica is a badass
animator and she's also just a killer
artist in general she actually gave me a
if you look back into the archive she
gave me a print of one of her original
pieces was pretty amazing
one of the biggest hearted people I know
in fact thank yous to Erica because I
saw her just recently and she presented
me with this passion planner there's
anybody I know who exudes warmth and
passion and who is good at like working
on that stuff it's Erica and and Greg
Greg Greg and Erica just the Union there
she's the female version of you and so I
can't thank you enough for just being
you for being warm and for exuding art
and all that you do shouts out to you
Erica Tuesday on a Monday afternoon what
are we gonna have that threesome
[Music]
well I hope you got a good vote nice old
buddy cuz you ain't seen this chemical
bleach booty again there we go gladiator
[Music]
Davy I'm so excited
[Music]
[Music]
show me what you got oh man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for attending my
seminar how to be more than just a
one-time the key concept none of you
possess it I paid $75 mark for this
thing it's not even sorry looky okay
yeah I'm making three appearances
lacking a key ingredient let's put a
smile on that face
there's plenty important to go around
sugar in there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
oh you really suck at sand
that's supposed to be well I couldn't
help notice your suit has no nipples how
do you plan on feeding your young man I
shot him in the chest go back to the
swamp shrek weren't you on the good side
good
I went back in time and still your mojo
[Laughter]
[Music]
where did I see what I can do with just
one glove I got the power
[Music]
Oh Gramps I don't know if you've heard
but I'm kind of on the outs with mum and
dad with you welcome to the family oh
well I was waiting for someone else to
say it but I'm not going to wait all day
[Music]
there goes wrath but slowly greed lost
pride you're the one I've been waiting
for spring
[Music]
[Music]
I need my baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can have money but this toy contains
small parts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh god until queen Godzilla has to show
up now I'm flattered your highness but
you're not my time seems twas ugly kill
the Beast
why did burn some lamp you
[Music]
[Music]
nobody think or say anything hey I could
really use a tripod or Laurel eyes
[Music]
I don't know why but I've got a real
problem with you buddy what a defeated
by common bacteria my new weapon of
choice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Jesse what have I been smoking
[Music]
no more mr. Roboto Turin H exhibition
[Music]
oh there's some fuel that's like two
haven't been converted to the ancient
Smith or enchantress causes hands up
who'd rather be nice kickin agent in a
well tailored suit than a walking toward
with a Thousand Eyes is it too late to
switch providers [ __ ]
prepare to be Smith here's the thing did
you think this was the real me DC goes
together I like what you're selling lady
there's just one teeny problem that's my
friends
my party - why don't you ever want to be
my friend
oh this contrast if you're going to do
it where no one can ha
your powers are beatable but it wasn't
always when were you humans learn why
waste years developing power when you
can just take it lesson learned
[Music]
that's MIT ever and no one to play ball
[Music]
[Music]
I like what you've got a boy from marvel
and a girl from DC I'm getting a major
Romeo and Juliet got a deeper to what
I'm really more into taps than scars
also you seem to be lacking in a few key
areas
oh no these grow back into full-sized
muscular appendages Barbie I know you
you're an Academy Award huh the Academy
Award lives inside a Golden Globe it's
true
on your industries greatest industry you
mean what are you talking about iMovie
animated all that you know I'm sitting I
see what's going on here see she can't
break the fourth wall just yet
we are movie characters and Earth movies
[Music]
different angles I don't recall seeing a
spider-man this much ever fine once off
plus I have tickets to these things it's
got all her money so how many times have
I one is for be your first first time if
you ask me ridiculously who usually wins
the hero
[Music]
you could have done that at any time
how can a stop for days you two should
get some rest
what with your big showdown tomorrow so
we fight each other to the death you
regenerate us and we are not fighting
again and again forever what exactly is
our incentive you as if you do fight you
won't experience
[Music]
to anyone listening you have a new
message from Jean Grey he's not joking
revolutions adapt arise yeah you'd think
I'd be accustomed to seeing blue people
by now what about pepper I take it you
both got miss Gray's message this Oscar
being has abused the power to create
life he must be stopped we were created
to fight I say we do so glad to see
we're all on the same page
good just the muted I need you to bring
everyone in here you mean all the heroes
no I mean everyone
[Music]
we're gonna take all the Oscars Wow
hey guys Deadpool here breaking the
fourth wall again you know I don't even
see wall to me it's a big open window I
just wanted to let you know that this
and every tune sandwich is the work of
two people they live in Australia and
they have no connections to anything if
you haven't already you can help them
and if you're feeling super generous you
can even spoke to my channel
nice fourth wall break right yeah my
club has really grown beyond what I
intended don't know what have I told you
about talking to strange men
if you guys don't shut up I'm gonna buy
your hands all we need was Nick Cage to
show up to go rob Vagan Oh base off man
yeah I thought their superhero Bowl was
was wildly impressive I thought that was
already exhilarating oh if as it is so I
was well aware of what I was getting
into with this just I was you don't
remember the Super Hero Bowl remember I
showed it to you forever ago there's the
same kind of concept just with a bunch
of superheroes is this one like his feet
crazier this one's crazier for sure it's
definitely longer there's an actual plot
behind it in the end of it all maybe
that's why I don't remember as well
because this one is so intricate and it
gets like meta at the end breaks the
fourth wall and has this weird like
double reality where people are like
finding out they're in movies and stuff
well yeah it's setting it up for an
actual kind of plot in a storyline and
the last one which was a superhero which
is just craziness references my favorite
thing is when they have actors who play
the same characters match up with each
other like how they had Agent Smith in
Red Skull the Red Skull talking with
each other there was a million Angelina
Jolie yeah I thought they got really
creative though when Darth Vader had the
xenomorph baby and a lightsabers and now
arms to the animation with what they do
is wildly impressive because they all
look exactly like the characters i
voices are great I don't think there's
one character here I didn't recognize
this takes a lot of outlining I think I
bet before they write any dialogue for
anything I bet they have to outline the
hell out of this especially because I
find it so clever when they have like Oh
with all the horror movie characters
keep stabbing yeah yeah and all the
different like lizard dinosaur-like
creatures all that have really eat each
other and going who would mash up with
whom mess and everything and whose power
might be able to work as a reference to
another movie like when yeah the whole
Indiana Jones thing it's really
impressive how it's just these two
people who do this man yeah
they haven't uploaded in like four
months and then I was still doing their
channel and come back with this you're
like oh yeah wondering upload I see
because this right here is an ultimate
ass project and I appreciate that
they're actually trying to convert it
into some type of store in line this
time around because they kind of teased
it there could be a storyline and now
they're really building to that right
here I'm wondering what the next one is
that they could actually do you know
they did superhero Bowl that did the
super villain Bowl and I do a lot of
these trailer spoofs now I'm wondering
what the next step is for these guys
well there's so much of this that has
like a fanfiction II sort of element
like oh yeah characters would you like
to see square off so I imagine if we're
going into the next one we're gonna have
all the heroes and all the villains like
coming up to take on this oscar alien
creature I can only imagine we're gonna
see like even cooler matchups
yeah and characters we've always wanted
to see fight and we'll probably see some
new characters too you know I think a
ready player one because of the amount
of references and stuff but you see I'm
ready player one these are people and
avatars so that they don't get the
actual personalities of those characters
what's cool about this is you're getting
the actual personalities of the
characters be attached up together
oh yeah it's a free-for-all yeah it's
freaking beautiful like how they dubbed
this man really impressed I don't know
how they arrived at the idea that like
the Joker would become the thing but
that's one of my favorite like nerdy
Easter egg surprises I've seen in
anything I'm just watching him like
alien out and then his head sprouts away
I was in nerd heaven at that moment
thank you guys arts for entertainment
ma'am please go after this channel we're
definitely subscribed to these guys I
mean your tune sandwich series is
freakin awesome and I love all the
trailers you guys do please keep up at
it guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
love to see you soon guys bye